oh that's it
vulcan week is officially over or has it
just begun
hey what's up guys my name is the
channel i thought i would do a little
bit of a post-mortem
update of what happened during
welcome week for those of you who do not
know and did not see my video on monday
this entire week i've been working
on implementing or adding vulcan support
to hazel
my game engine and of course i've been
streaming the entire thing
on twitch it's been a pretty intense
week to say the least it's really
interesting to take on kind of a
week-long challenge
like this because to be honest this kind
of reminds me of back in the day when i
had a full-time job working for ea
and i actually showed up every day and i
worked i
i sat down at my desk and i wrote code
for the whole day
i don't think i've had that feeling
pretty much since i quit that job
because
youtube is all over the place like i'm
making videos i'm teaching students i'm
live streaming i'm all of this
lots of stuff going on but with this
vulcan week challenge
sitting down actually spending some time
on the code
was a very welcome change i think for
myself even though
it was vulcan and we had a lot of
problems along the way of course but
overall i thought it went great did i
mention that this video is sponsored by
skillshare i don't think i did this
video is sponsored by
skillshare have you guys heard of
skillshare skillshare is an amazing
online learning community where millions
of creative and curious people from all
around the world come together into this
one place
to learn new skills learning new skills
is what i've been doing all week and
whilst vulcan is probably a little bit
too complicated for skillshare
for stuff that can be taught in little
bite-sized chunks skillshare is
hands-down the best platform i've ever
come across whether you want to learn
about
art illustration marketing business
productivity i mean i could probably
just keep listing topics off the top of
my head and skillshare would have them
scotia is by far one of the best places
on the internet to learn about
that kind of stuff i've mentioned
through our previous videos that their
illustration classes are top-notch and
to be honest one of the best things i
think i could do for myself mentally
right now is to sit down and actually do
some art just do some illustration
offline away from a computer
after this crazy week and just relax
maybe play some smooth jazz music in the
background
and just make myself a nice pot of tea
coming in at just under 10
a month for an annual subscription as
well skillshare is
amazing value and i mean for all of the
stuff it's going to teach you
if you're not quite sure if skillshare
has any classes that might interest you
well just try it out for free because
skillshare is offering two months
of free skillshare premium to the first
1000 people who click
the link in the description below and
sign up so definitely check it out and
see if there are any classes that you
are
into and thank you once again to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
somewhat surprisingly i think or at
least it kind of surprised me
i think one of the hardest things that i
encountered during this week
was myself it was
forcing myself to be able to sit down
and actually
solve all of the problems and when
you're live streaming you kind of have
to do that you can't just bail and be
like okay well i'm gonna
go and procrastinate now no there's
hundreds of people watching you you need
to keep going and you want to keep going
it's not like you want to quit it's just
that sometimes
things get tough and you have to learn
to live with that but aside from simply
your brain wanting to do something else
i think it's also important to consider
your body and your mental state and
how healthy you are if you can't look
after yourself
then sitting down and trying to be an
amazing programmer and make a game
engine by yourself which is what i'm
doing
it's not going to happen you need to
you need to look after yourself i mean
i'm sitting here thinking about
this week and reflecting on everything
that's happened but hopefully some of
this is going to be helpful
to you guys and honestly look after
yourselves make sure that you
make sure that you stay healthy i wasn't
really sleeping very well this week it's
not that i was going to bed late i
really wasn't but i just i guess i just
had a lot going on mentally
and i found it a little bit difficult to
fall asleep and then i would wake up
a little bit early and the first thing
i'd be thinking about would be like the
live stream and the game engine and
vulcan
and all this stuff i just i i found it
difficult sometimes to switch off and to
take a break and i think that when that
starts happening
you're in kind of dangerous territory
now what did i do to counter that well
starting from tuesday i actually went
for a run
every single morning before the live
stream i don't really know how this
happened it was kind of spontaneous i
mean i've wanted to
exercise more often than i'm doing at
the moment
but it was just such a sunny beautiful
day and i just thought about
sitting down and being at my desk the
whole day live streaming i was like why
why don't i go
outside especially with this kind of
current lockdown situation we have in
melbourne where you can't really
i mean you can't even go five kilometers
past where you live catching some
sunlight catching some fresh air going
for a run around the block is
it's such an easy thing to do it takes
like 10 minutes
and immediately instead of just being
all like just
stretching and feeling bad i just i felt
energized the blood was flowing i sat
down and my
my mood was instantly improved i think i
mean it's crazy every time i exercise
every time i go to the gym every time i
do some weights anytime i go for a run i
always come out of it thinking man that
was amazing i feel so good
i feel i feel like i'm alive you know
and then yet next week
i can go a whole week without even
without even doing anything i don't know
why it keeps happening maybe that just
goes to
to show like where my mind is at and how
i'm distracted with certain things i
think i like a little bit of discipline
to be completely honest
but getting on top of that
helped me get on top of vulcan
and don't underestimate that i really
hope i'm in focus because
i have to put the aperture way way way
down or should i say up
to try and uh account for this low-light
situation i mean i would set up some
more lights and stuff but i mean let's
be honest i'm pretty tired let's get
some better let's get more lights up in
a here bit of orange you know really
hits the spot okay so
going back to where it all began
so i just wrapped up day four and i
thought that i'd give you guys a little
bit of an update
as to how today went because today was
probably
the best day of falcon week so far if we
go back a little bit and we just
take a look at the general timeline of
how these days were spent
monday was mostly me still preparing for
vulcan there was
a lot of making sure that all of the
v-shaders
were working correctly making sure open
gel worked with the uniform buffers i
think i had a
a bug at the end of the day where for
some reason like they weren't binding to
my binding points correctly
but that whole day was basically still
still deep inside
opengl no vulcan code written yeah just
making sure that all of my opengl
shaders would play nicely
with vulcan and then the next day on
tuesday i got up i fixed
that shader bug and the binding point
bug with the uniform buffers
and then from there things got a little
bit easier for a bit and in fact i think
by the end of the day we even started
exploring some falcon code but in
general those two days the first two
days of welcome week were spent doing
basically no vulcan code
whatsoever it was just getting gl to
work getting
our existing hazel renderer and the
whole hazel engine to actually
be compatible with falcon and opengl
because of course we're not taking
opengl away
we're adding vulcan as an additional
renderer api
from there though i think we did a
little bit of welcome code at the very
end of tuesday day two but then day
three
we started off just going full speed
ahead on
vulcan we basically set up a vulcan
instance all the vulcan devices
stuff we talked about like queues and
queue families and making sure that we
have
all of the swap chain working i think
for the most part
we our goal for day three was to
actually make sure that we had a clear
color
and a swap chain that we could like
resize the window and it would resize
all the swap chain buffers and
everything was working correctly with
the swap chain
which it was by day three i think that i
think day three went pretty well
but at that point i was feeling a little
bit tired and i mentioned this
during the stream as well that it just i
just didn't feel like i was at my peak
i you can probably tell by watching the
stream as well that it wasn't
like i wasn't really enjoying myself
that much and
i was feeling a little bit fatigued and
i just needed to take care of myself a
little bit more i think so i made sure
that i
took the evening off and relaxed and
also that i went to bed early
and i could actually sleep in on day
four
because all the other days i had to get
up like around seven to eight
am to do other work but i was able to
sleep in today and today is day four
so i think that that made a huge
difference because today was
as i said by far the best day i mean i
was just i was just in such a good mood
i felt so happy i've been exercising as
well which has really helped i think
and just taking better care of myself i
was just in the zone today i mean i was
writing code really quickly everything
made sense to me there was very few gaps
where i just thought about
like what do i even do or how do i do
this nothing's working everything was
just me typing as fast as i could
basically
to get everything in which which is just
so good so i just wanted to say
that like and i'll probably end up
making tomorrow night i think i'll end
up making a little bit more of a recap
uh when uh vulcan week's officially
officially over but
so far man just you know making sure
that you're healthy and taking care of
yourself
is i think number one priority at this
point i mean we just had such a good day
we started today off with clearing up
some of the swap chain stuff and
refactoring a lot of that code moving
all the code from context to swap chain
and just
you know shuffling around hazel's
classes to make sure that it made sense
and that it was in the right spot
and then we just like i don't know what
do we do we did shaders we did pipelines
we did
vertex buffers index buffers descriptor
sets descriptor set layouts you know
uniform buffers in vulcan everything up
to the point where we now have a sphere
rendering that we can actually use the
camera to move around
with as well so i mean pretty cool stuff
and i think that it was only like a five
and a half to six hour stream as well
but
our goal for the day was to get a
triangle up and we got an entire sphere
with like you know a camera and
everything up and running
so i think that's absolutely amazing and
technically we could learn any 3d model
as well because everything is flowing
through hazel's existing renderer it's
just being rendered in vulcan
so yeah really good day and i guess all
i wanted to say with this little update
was that
um taking care of yourself makes such a
big difference and i think that's
probably going to be the theme of this
whole video to be honest
anyway future channel is probably still
talking about you know
how vulcan week ended now i'm looking at
the time and to be honest
i think i should probably make myself
some dinner maybe and relax instead of
making a video for the rest of today
especially after this
exhausting week so i might actually make
a follow-up video maybe on the weekend
maybe a little bit later i could talk
for hours about how this week went
i don't know if anyone cares to be
honest but
i think tonight is not going to be the
night that i do that so now i know that
a lot of people have been asking me
where they can watch those live streams
i'm making them available to patrons so
patreon confers out to the channel which
is the best way to support me and
everything i'm doing there are several
different tiers on patreon but
if you're a supporter level 2 or higher
you will get access to
my whole backlog of recorded live
streams so that's that's just like all
of them not just this falcon week
but you can also access uh the vods on
twitch if you're a subscriber but twitch
only keeps them for 60 days
so if you're watching this and it's more
than 60 days old then
first of all hello from the past
second of all maybe hop on patreon and
obviously
just because vulcan week is drawing to
an end uh or is over probably by the
time you're watching this doesn't mean
that that's it with vulcan we're
obviously
we obviously have a lot of work ahead
this was just the initial kind of sprint
to try and get everything in there and
just you know spend as much time and
hard work as possible into getting it up
and running which i think we
will hopefully would have successfully
done again this is day four when i'm
filming this regardless though thank you
all for your support i don't think i
could have made it through this vulcan
week without an amazing group of people
watching my live streams and
just keeping me motivated keeping me
happy talking to me
this community means a lot i've said
that so many times but i honestly from
the bottom of my heart thank you guys
for
for being around and for caring about
hazel and everything i'm doing
thank you don't forget to check out
skillshare in the uh description below
as well because the first 1000 people
as i mentioned will get free two months
of skillshare premium
thank you guys for watching love you all
have a great day nice
whatever i enjoyed this week it was an
absolute blast
later guys goodbye
[Music]
you